in thinking about how the course has to
evolve given the availability of all
this of all this new technology one
thing I've especially thought about
worried about actually is is how much of
my own lecture material which I now have
on video to make available to them as
against my live performance and whether
my life performance is even necessary at
all how does it differ from and I'm
still not I still haven't worked that
out for two semesters now I have taught
the course with a combination of live
lectures and video lectures and I've
asked the students to tell me in
commentaries whether they saw much
difference in whether they preferred one
to the other or whether they had strong
feelings and so far the the testimony
has been met they don't seem too
interested in the question and which
makes me a little nervous actually so my
feeling is that it's still an open
question one thing I definitely have
decided I will be able to do with this
video material is use it in other
courses if I teach an advanced course in
film and students haven't taken my
earlier film course I can send them to
this material and have them use it so
it's immensely valuable as a teaching
tool but how to integrate it into the
existing course remains a conundrum I
haven't quite figured out as I've begun
to work on this now it's been some years
since I've started to have some video
lectures available I think I realized
that I was naive in imagining that the
transition would be easy that moving to
a video format was simply the matter of
transferring what I say because in fact
the live environment turns out to be
more central and more important and my
feelings as I'm in the live environment
turn out to be more essential and more
important than they might otherwise be
there's something about being in a live
environment that affects me and I think
other teachers not maybe not all
teachers what other teachers very deeply
I used to have the fantasy what I was
before in front of a large audience of
students may be as many as a hundred or
a hundred and fifty i had the delusion
or illusion that i that i was in touch
with every student in the class and that
I actually understand that every single
one of them was paying attention and
that when they didn't I could feel it
and then I could see there was a student
who'd stop paying attention I would
somehow find walk in that direction of
the class or get that students attention
no I'm sure it was a fantasy because how
could you be aware of a hundred students
but I had the illusion that I was aware
of them I was certainly aware of many of
them I was aware of them as individuals
I was aware of whether and I I felt I
had them wrapped and when I when I felt
I was losing them i would change pace i
was away maybe it has something to do
with a theatrical aspect to me that
really doesn't help much with being a
good teacher but is really but maybe it
does help with being a good teacher and
that maybe maybe good teachers do have
to have a bit of the ham in them and and
like being in front of audiences this is
a special problem for the Western
because it celebrates American
individualism so powerfully the iconic
scene of the Western in which two men
wearing guns square off against each
other and the quicker one survives that
scene of the quick draw and of the death
and the dusty street is it could be said
to be a kind of embodiment of these
values in which you have to rely on
yourself you can't run and you can't
rely on someone else you can't rely on
the government you can't rely on the
sheriff you can't rely on the police you
can't rely on your neighbors you have to
trust yourself and in fact one of the
ways you can see the power of these
Western mythology's operating as it
seems to me in some sense one of the
great divides in the United States today
over the question of guns and gun
control is partly grounded in these
myths of individualism that Western that
the Western mythology has been
promulgating since the since before the
advent of the movies and I think part of
what makes my teaching good is that I
I'm in a kind of trance when I'm in
front of a class in the sense that I am
utterly oblivious to what i look like i
know for one thing I have done teachers
nightmare kinds of things like having my
shirt on but
without realizing it or coming in with
my hair incredibly ask you without
knowing about it once I gave a lecture
at Yale I had young children at the time
and I had a child my wife was with the
two other children I had to take a child
to a doctor they took him at out I took
him to the doctor but I had to go to
give my lecture so I took him into the
lecture hall and I SAT him down in the
corner of the lecture and he was about
seven years old and he said nicely in
the seat for a little while I wasn't
paying attention to him then he climbed
up I was lecturing on a stage and he
climbed up on the stage and he went
behind me and he sat in a big chair
behind me he made faces and the student
I the students began to laugh and I
couldn't understand what was going on
but it taught me a great lesson in the
in the theatrical reality of the lecture
of the lecture hall as so I've come more
fully to understand that things that are
hard to articulate her or that I at
least had not much thought about
certainly have not been written about in
pedagogical literature about the
ambience of the live classroom has some
effect on lecturing I mean it should
have effect in smaller classrooms even
more fully I think but in among let for
lecturers I think it's important to and
the transition to purely video lectures
losses that how big a loss that is or
whether that loss can be compensated for
in other ways is a good question